we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P here's a caller who is
disgusted with the hate mob Unleashed
upon me by Donald Trump Jr listen to
this
hi David I just saw your video regarding
the Tweet you removed I think you did
the right thing I but you know removing
it I guess because
imagine the hypocrisy of these people
there first of all anyone who knows who
listens to you should know
exactly what you meant by that tweet
um so that's disturbing but the fact
that they would threaten you and your
family come on people this is what they
do it's just
just disgusting yes and you are correct
um obviously if thoughts and prayers
stop this we wouldn't have this problem
and I do agree you know I think people
if they if prayer works for them that's
great do that but we need to take action
legislatively pray but allow politicians
to do things
um you know and call and write and just
press our all our representatives of the
local state and federal levels
this is inexcusable and one thing that I
feel like never gets discussed really in
the mainstream media at least is the
fact that the GOP is in bed with the NRA
of course and in fact in my video that I
did yesterday I do discuss it because it
must be discussed uh accurate voicemail
I have nothing to add we have a great
voice a bonus show for you today we will
talk about Joe Biden's reaction to the
Nashville shooting and his urging of an
assault weapons ban we're also going to
talk about hand scanning technology
rolled out at Panera that has privacy
Advocates very concerned are they
warranted in being concerned we will
discuss and lastly a conspiracy theory
about a body double for John fetterman
has actually gotten a bunch of attention
it's pretty nuts we will talk about all
of it on the bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com use the coupon code
cancel cancel to get yourself a discount